es gran victoria para bailén pero
también es una gran victoria para
activistas y abanderados de la causa
climática sin duda es una gran noticia
efectivamente algo que estábamos
esperando ya hace algún tiempo era parte
de las promesas cierto también
obviamente
de cuando fue electo el presente bain
pero también es una buena noticia
justamente en estos momentos económicos
que se vive porque trae muy buenas
particularmente muy buenas cosas que
tienen que ver con gente de escasos
recursos con los hogares que reciben
menos y que podrían tener ahorros
también importantísimo lo cual no
solamente ayuda a esta gente sino que
ayuda a la transición justamente a la
energía más sustentable y limpia ahora
la suma aprobada está muy por debajo de
los más de 500 mil millones de dólares
que los demócratas pedían sigue siendo
esto un respiro en materia
medioambiental
si lo que se proyecta básicamente
y con este paquete se puede alcanzar al
2030 al menos la mitad de las promesas
de la reducción ante el accord en parís
obviamente eso no es la totalidad
todavía hoy estamos lejos pero es un
paso importantísimo en este momento y yo
quiero también recalcar que aún cuando
son 370 millones y miles de millones es
una de las cosas importantes que había
básicamente es cierto en el continente
es cierto
unas cien veces menos de eso es decir
había un gasto de cuatro mil millones de
dólares hasta él hasta el momento por lo
tanto estamos hablando de cien veces de
incrementos eso es importantísimo y creo
que hay que resaltarlo sin embargo como
tú entras bien decías hay también
negociaciones que se tuvieron que hacer
para alcanzar finalmente este voto
positivo del senado pero recordemos
también que todavía tienen que ir a la
casa a la clase de representantes a la
cámara de representes exactamente este
rechazo de los republicanos a cuestiones
medioambientales les puede o puede ser
castigado en las urnas en las elecciones
de medio término
yo creo que puede ser castigado yo creo
que hoy día también estamos viviendo
como digo un cambio importantísimo aquí
en el país en el planeta es como ustedes
saben también hay cada vez mucho más
conciencia que efectivamente lo cambio
que estamos viviendo una ola ola de
calor en europa en estos momentos cierto
también una ola de calor la y también
las cosas que hemos visto en la última
semana cierto de inundaciones históricas
en algunos estados y yo creo que también
hace muy presente que este ya no tiene
que ver con un tema necesariamente tanto
de empleo de ccoo republicano pero sobre
todo que tiene que ver con la humanidad
y yo creo que ese mensaje está cambiando
me parece que interesante ver cierto aun
cuando fue muy peleada la votación el 50
por ciento
es altísimo no fue fácil conseguir al
barrio de los senadores y como digo
también tuvo sus repercusiones en
algunos de los puntos que pueden
preocupar como por ejemplo ciertos son
las perforaciones en el golfo de
california el perdón de de méxico y
también en alaska pero sin embargo yo
creo que justamente como tú dice para
hacer cosas que en este cerca no van a
seguir adelante claro